le président de la SN de l'époque et
Monsieur de rosuk la rappeler avait dès
2013 souligné dans le débat national sur
la transition énergétique que le système
électrique ne disposait pas des marges
nécessaires pour faire face à
l'indisponibilité pour une raison de
sûreté générique d'une dizaine de
réacteurs on sait qu'on a pas fait grand
chose depuis entre le retard sur les
renouvelables la France est le seul pays
à avoir raté son objectif européen en
2020 la faiblesse des actions de
maîtrise de la demande et le frein à la
fermeture des réacteurs pour diversifier
et réduire cette dépendance et cet hiver
nous y sommes précisément au type de
situation que décrivait pierre Franck
chevet
cette situation elle nous elle nous
expose en fait mécaniquement à un
arbitrage par nature malsain entre eux
sécurité électrique et sur tes nucléaire
qui se double dans le contexte de crise
énergétique que nous connaissons d'une
pression induite par l'envolée des prix
de marché
que les perspectives données par EDF
avec une prévision d'appel 50% de
facteurs de charge du pack nucléaire
pour 2022 et à peine plus pour 2023 ont
évidemment exacerbé EDF a beaucoup
communiqué sur une application
volontaire et vertueuse du principe de
précaution lorsque les premiers
résultats ont conduit au constat rappelé
sur civoins en arrêtant préventivement
les quatre réacteurs du palier M4 mais
on peut constater que le même principe
de précaution n'a pas été appliqué
lorsque un problème a été détecté sur un
réacteur du palier pprme 4 en lien et on
peut clairement y voir le poids de
l'impact qu'aurait eu la même
application du principe de précaution
sur la sécurité électrique plus
largement on a vu me semble-t-il
l'évolution générale l'orientation
générale du dossier évolué sous cette
pression des enjeux d'approvisionnement
électrique